all right hi everyone
my name is jens puschoff i'm a phd
candidate with
hans clevas in utrecht i will talk today
about organoids so 3d tissue culture
systems
and in particular recent developments
for stories which we have published last
year
with a particular focus on organs of the
snake venom gland
and how we studied bacterial
contributions to colorectal cancer using
the organoids
at the end of my talk i want to give a
one slide sneak peek into two other
projects
one on the novel coronal virus and how
we can model infection with this virus
with organoids
and the rare intestinal cell types and
also how organs help us understanding
these things
with the very first slide i want to give
an intro on organized so what i'm
talking about are adult stencil-derived
organoids so we can grow them from
patient biopsies or from animal biopsies
we can expand them indefinitely in
culture they're genetically stable so
you don't need any transformation step
to grow them
they grow in 3d we embed them in
three-dimensional
matrix matrijo or basement membrane
extract to grow
and they are heterogeneous they contain
both the stem cell but also the
differentiated cell types of the
particular organ they are derived from
with adult stem cell derived organelles
we grow only the epithelium
but not the mesenchymes so they're a
reductionist model system but can be
very useful to study exactly these
epithelial
processes and finally as mentioned a
single
stem cell can be enough to grow an
entire argonaut model
in the first star i want to talk about
we grew the first reptilian organized
system
from the snake venom gland and this has
been a collaboration
with joric post and uber in the lab but
also a large group of collaborators
worldwide to get all these snakes
and understand what's happening in these
organized
we started out with four main
motivations uh to do this
first we wanted to learn something about
stem cell biology because organoids were
first arrived in 2009
and in the last 10 years we've learned a
lot about how adult stencils work
in mammals but if these principles would
be conserved also in reptile
that was not clear so first of all i
wanted to understand how conserved adult
stem cell biology is
beyond mammals second
venom production itself is a fascinating
process and it's pretty hard to study
for
uh you cannot just crisp or a snake and
they have longer generation time than
mice
so it would be really useful to get
organized from uh from snakes to be able
to study these processes of venom
production and secretion
in more detail third snake bite is a
major global health problem there's more
than 100 000 deaths each year
based on snake bite and the anti-venom
productions so largely relies on
uh having large amounts of the venom
itself so we thought if we can
standardize this process we could help
to make a next generation of anti-venoms
based on organoids
and finally the toxins in the venom are
also
uh quite biologically active substances
uh and there are six fda approved drugs
based on snake venom
so we thought probably that's a good one
to um produce the venom biotechnological
biotechnologically with the organoids
and see if we can use them as a
production platform
for these bioactive molecules while this
motivational mind we set out to
derive the first organoids and the
process was surprisingly easy
what you see up here is the the protocol
which is very similar to what we do for
mammals
here we often started with an egg with
late stage embryos
dissected out the venom gland
dissociated it to
small chunks of tissue so probably 30
cells a piece
and then we embedded them in this
three-dimensional scaffold
and they started growing into cystic
organoids looking very similar to what
we get for most mammalian organs
the main difference is that they grow at
32 degrees more closely recapitulating
the body temperature of a snake
very interestingly as a first finding we
saw that the growth factors required to
support the growth of these adult stem
cells two organoids
are very similar to what we know from
mouse and human and these are even mouse
and human growth factors so they are
conserved enough to support the growth
of snake stem cells
just highlighting how conserved these
key stem cell pathways are
when we published the paper last year we
had nine species established and you see
them all here very colorful snakes
but the argonauts look reasonably
similar under the bright field
microscope
so to give you a better overview of what
they really look like i have a short
video here
on the fluorescence microscopy and we
see as we fly through one of these
organoids that they're a monolayered
epithelium
they're quite polarized with an actin
layer towards the middle
shown in blue here and just coming back
up
and we even can spot some dividing cells
up there for example
in the organoid to really understand
what's going on in the argonauts we
went one step further and performed a
transmission electron microscopy
and this was the first one we started
thinking that they could really produce
venom because when you
look at this you see a monolayer
epithelium in nucleus towards the
basolateral side
but you also see a lot of vesicles
towards the apical side of these cells
filled with
gray or even black substance and when
you compare this to an image of
a real venom gland you see quite a
striking resemblance of these
vesicles which are known to be filled
with venom in the original gland
interestingly we also see heterogeneity
here so one organoid differentiated very
well
and you see dark vesicles here at the
bottom and the dark filling of the
organoid
whereas the organ on the top of the
screen did not differentiate as well and
you see that there's
no dark substance inside so we're
wondering do these arguments keep
accumulating venom in the middle
and to address the question we teamed up
with jurgen klopp and julian slagbomb
in amsterdam to characterize what's in
there so we
lysed the organs we got whatever was in
the lumen and then
they ran lcms to characterize the
protein profile in there
and indeed when we compare the real
snake venom on the top and the organ of
supernatural at the bottom
we see a lot of traces which have an
extremely high correspondence in size
and when our collaborators run from the
digest to characterize what is produced
by those what are these peaks
we see that these are mostly belonging
to the family of three finger toxins and
that's a class of neurotoxins
from um the snakes all of these data
here are from aspergillus lubricals
which is the cape coral snake in our
poster child snake for for this project
basically
these three finger toxins are most well
known for
blocking the action of acetylcholine
receptors and so our next question was
now that we know that these organelles
make venom
is it also functional and to check that
we teamed up with mimetas
biotech company in leiden in the
netherlands and they have
so-called myotubes on the organoplate so
these are
mouse muscle saline cultures grown in
these fibers
which express acetylcholine receptors
and when exposed to a green calcium dye
you do see that waves of calcium signal
are propagating through these myotubes
and the video down here is already
playing so the toxin exposed ones where
we
took the organoid venom and we exposed
the myotubes with them
and we see that these green signals are
gone we can also
quantify this and see that need there is
a lot of calcium wave propagation
in the controlled exposed molecules at
the top and this signal is almost gone
with the toxin exposed cultures and the
quantification looks like this
and serving as evidence that the organic
supernatant is enough to block
the firing of myotubes which is very
similar to a snake by paralyzing
muscles of a victim great work again by
mimitas and please
nicodevas thunderspikers and thomas
oliver here
with that we had uh one remaining big
question and this is
the cellular heterogeneity of the venom
gland it's not really clear
if there's one cell type making all the
different toxins which make up venom
because venom is a mixture
of dozens of different compounds of
their specialized cell types
contributing
the different toxins to address this we
perform single cell rna sequencing on
our argonoids and primary venom gland
tissue
so this is the teeth knee map from
singles for rna sequencing data every
dot here is one cell
clustering by similarity we have two
different media
in yellow you see expansion medium so
where we're enriched for stem cells
and a black with differentiation medium
where we push them towards
the venom production what we know from
our experiments before
when we look at where the most toxins
are expressed
they really cluster in the lower half so
in the differentiated cells which makes
a lot of sense
but now our question was do different
cells make different toxins
indeed we see that there's population
down here which predominantly expresses
three finger toxins so the neurotoxins
we already were talking about earlier
and interestingly also cofactors for the
folding of these like protein
disorphadies on the rise here
extremely well corresponding with the
expression in each cell
but for other classes of toxins like the
c-type lectins we find different
populations
uh like marked in purple here on the
left for example
and uh for other toxins yet again we
have
more populations expressing these so
this is the first evidence that we could
really have different subpopulations of
venom gland cells
making different toxins
what we did to sum this up was to use
rna scopes of fluorescent lead
hybridizations to check where this
expression is located because we don't
have the spatial information in the
signals for rna sequencing
and when we look for example at this
cofactor the
papillator solvent or zomerase we do see
that
it is located in the glandular
structures but not so much in the stroma
or the duct of the venom gland just
adding some spatial information to the
patterns we observed
in our organelles things are only seek
to sum up this project we do uh
have three take home messages first
organelles are grown from adult stem
cell and we can grow out of stencil
derived organoids
not just from mammals but also from
reptiles so of course now
we and others are pursuing many
different species
to see how far we can stretch this
organic technology
beyond the traditional mouse and human
models
second the venom ground organizers of
the snake produce functional toxins what
we could
demonstrate with some chip assays
and finally we have some evidence of
heterogeneity in the venom gland of
cellular heterogeneity
meaning that different cell types could
be producing different toxins
which is a great basic science insight
on how this organ is organized
with that i want to move on to the next
project where the only two unifying
factors
are that we're using organized to make a
discovery and that we're talking about
toxins in one way or the other in this
project we set out to
check if bacteria can contribute
mutations to colorectal cancer
development
just like the last one it's a three phd
student collaboration
with caitanya pleguezuelos manzano and
axelrose dalhouba
in an introduction you may all be aware
of that we
that our gut harbors a lot of bacteria
many different species
some of which have beneficial effects
for our health
but others can also contribute to the
development of diseases
and one of those is called genotoxic e
coli
genotoxic e coli is pretty much a normal
e coli
just it does have a diff an additional
gene island the so-called pks
island and on this speaker as iron it
encodes a set of enzymes which produce
the genotoxin
colibactin so pks positive e coli
produce the genotoxic compound
colibactin and that's what we study in
this project
we started to answer one pretty
fundamental question and this is
can bacteria contribute specific
mutations in human cancer
and because colobactin is well known
these bacteria are well characterized
we chose these strains to address the
question
to check if specific mutations are
introduced we used another method
and this is called mutational signature
analysis
i think published first in 2013 it looks
at the context of where single mutations
happen
so here you see the examples of single
base substitution where one nucleotide
gets replaced
by one other shown in the middle here
like a c being replaced by an a
and we also take into account the base
one upstream and the base one downstream
of the mutation
so when we go through all of these
combinations we end up with 96
combinations
and now we can go through the genome of
a cancer patient and count
how often does each of these 96
combinations
happen and when we do this we plot all
the
96 combinations on the x-axis
and we count the mutations per
combination we get a profile or
mutational signature
and this has been found to be very
characteristic for many oncogenes or for
many uh
carcinogens whatever you can think of so
this for example is an example
of uv radiation and its mutational
footprint
where you see that c2t mutations are
enriched and in particular
in some special trinucleotide contexts
these have been found by now for a lot
of different cosmogenic factors
but they hadn't been described for
bacterium so we are looking for one of
these mutation signatures
caused by genotoxic e coli
to do this we used a wild type genotoxic
e coli strain
and an isogenic knockout where one of
these enzymes on the pks island is
removed
so they no longer secrete functional
kodi bacterium
serving as our negative control for
anything codibactin specific
so where do organelles come in this is
now they are
wildham epithelium as mentioned in the
beginning so we really start
with a very clean genotype we can grow
them clonally from a single cell so they
all start with the exact same genome
and now we can expose them to bacteria
because organoids are polarized and
their luminous site is also on the
inside of an organoid
we have to inject the bacteria to make
it as physiological as possible
and this is what we did and to allow
them to accumulate mutations
we did it over a time frame of three
months every two weeks injecting
bacteria
sometimes later removing them with
antibiotics
splitting the organoids and then
repeating the cycle
and what we're expecting or hoping for
was that in the wild that echola exposed
organoids
mutations would accumulate shown on the
left here
you can imagine that every single cell
will capture a different mutation so
sequencing whole organoids
may be very tricky to analyze in the end
so there's another advantage of organs
that we can grow them from single cells
so we can dissociate those and in the
second step we're clonal organoids
so this is what we did associating the
single cells growing clonal organoid
lines
and once we grow these clonal argument
lines
we can isolate their dna they will all
have the same genotype now
and capture just mutations which were
caused in one cell
throughout this co culture and in the
whole genome sequencing then we're
hoping to find
both non-specific mutations just through
normal replication errors
but also some specific mutations in the
wild
equally exposed organelles
so when we looked at all these single
base substitutions with mutational
signature analysis
we found the following things on the one
hand
in both the control bacteria and water
victory exposed organoids
we find a pretty broad background
signature which was expected
but only in the wild to bicola exposed
organoids
we find another signature and because
all of this was done in parallel we can
now subtract these background mutations
from the wild topical unused mutations
and by that come up with a pretty clean
signature
which we call sps pks this is for
single base substitutions caused by pks
e coli
and when we look at what kind of
mutations are
characterizing this signature we see
that everything here is a t to n
mutation so
simon and getting replaced by something
else and it's all in the context of
neighboring adenosines and thymines so
definitely
something about in silence going on with
that signature
these have all been animations if you
haven't noticed so
i'm going to show the real data now and
you see that it's
just the same this here is the walter
bicola induced signature
the background signature and the
subtraction derived spsp case
we can do this not just for single base
substitutions but also for
insertions and deletions and without
going to too much detail here
when we look at insertions and deletions
we find a strong enrichment of this
class which is the deletion of a single
thymidin
in a pony t stretch and i'll come to
that later
trying to understand what's going on a
little bit better we looked further than
just one base upstream and down screen
and this was really surprising this
project that it's not
the simon or admins in one base upstream
or downstream in the green bar here
which is most uh telling of the caller
signature
but it's really three bases upstream
that we have a striking enrichment of an
adenosine
on the same strand as the thymidine
which gets mutated
while we were pursuing this project
there were some great papers being
published in science on the chemistry of
colibactin
showing that it can bind to adenosine
and crosslink to adenosines in the dna
now taking these pieces of information
together we think the following thing
may be happening
this is that kodibactin is binding to
the adenosines on the paired strands of
dna
in about three bases distance so it's
cross-linking
adenosine into strands and during the
repair process
something goes wrong and we uh have a
thymid in the end
being replaced which of course also
means that on the paired strand
an adenosine will be replaced all of
this is
uh just circumstantial evidence from
these studies and i think this is really
the next exciting step
to understand this mechanism better
based on the characteristic mutational
patterns we found
we found a very similar pattern for the
indel signature
and this is that our polyt stretch here
is
has a poly a stretch directly adjacent
to it
so also here we think it may be
caulibactin binding to two paired
adenosines
but why exactly one of these gets
resolved with the deletion of a single t
and the other one by the replacement of
the t
is still pretty much unclear
so much for the molecular partial for
the organic part and of course as an
organized lab
we can get very excited about this but
in the end
we have to show that this is happening
in patients to be relevant
and this is what we tried in the second
part of this project
now that we have identified two
mutational signatures
in organoids seeing if they also happen
in colorectal cancer patients
and this we could indeed show so when
you look here we have
sps pks so our single base substitution
signature
and our indel signature and
what we did was analyze a cohort of more
than 3500 whole genome sequences of
metastatic cancer
of various different primary sources and
we asked the question
what percentage of their mutations is
best explained
by our new signature compared to all the
other signatures
and when we do this we see that only a
small sub-population of all these 3500
metastases
has a large number of mutations caused
by sbs-pks and idpks
and when you look at the color almost
all of them are orange meaning that
they're coming from
codoracular primary cancer which is i
think a great finding we start with the
gut bacterium injected to organoids
identify these signatures and when we
look for them in patients
again we find them back in the color and
rectum
showing that most likely they're indeed
caused by a gut bacterium
you also see a lot of grey dots here
which are all the different cancer types
so
they don't have a large contribution and
an occasional
head and neck and urinary tract cancer
with a high contribution of these
signatures
and uh this these are both organs which
get infected by e coli
but which have not been implicated with
picasso cola as much so we think this
could be a great starting point to start
looking
into other cancers beyond the colon for
these mutational signatures
and for contributions of picas e coli
more than just the presence of random
mutations we could identify
a number of patients with potential
driver mutations
caused by the spks and idpks
for example these are patients with a
mutation apc so one of the most
prominent colorectal cancer driver genes
and every red dot here is one patient
with a
premature truncation apc caused by sps
pks or idpks
meaning that indeed these bacteria could
be contributing to driver
uh gene mutations and this is something
which we're also investigating right now
to what extent they play a functional
role in the early stages
of colorectal cancer initiation
to summarize this part we set out to
look for first mutational signature
caused by bacteria in human cancer
and using an organoid experiment with a
long-term exposure to these bacteria
we identify two mutation signatures sps
pks
and idpks
when we look for these mutation
signatures now in patients we find that
they're enriched in actually two large
cohorts of colorectal cancer by now
and we're talking about seven percent of
patients who have high levels of these
signatures so it's a reasonably large
proportion of colorectal cancer
with a high number of these mutations
with this we're thinking that uh we may
we still need to develop a better
understanding of when exactly these
bacteria act
they're found pretty early and these
signatures are found
pretty early and supposedly healthy
crips so we think this may be an early
life event and right now we're trying to
figure this out to
much earlier detect when these bacteria
cause mutations
and potentially think about ways to
prevent them like by removing the
bacteria in a targeted way
or interfering with the action of the
toxins
before these mutations occur
and finally there's a probiotic strain e
coli nissa
which contains e coli with the
pks operon and we're right now checking
if these bacteria could also cause these
mutations it's really early days
this is an investigation and just
finding your signature and organisms of
course
will not mean that these probiotics
cause mutations
in patients but still we think it's
worthwhile
looking into this and understanding if
if missile e coli can also cause
mutations in patients
my last two slides i want to briefly
present to other projects
which also show how we can use organoids
to rapidly understand new areas of
biology
the first uh was led by three other phd
students this time mart llamas euberman
and elder thunderfart and i was helping
a bit with the
bioinformatics part in this project and
this is about understanding
how the new coronavirus infects cells in
a particular
intestinal cell of course we can grow
organelles from many different tissues
but in the intestine they're really well
characterized
so we thought about trying this if
coronavirus can affect intestinal cells
using organized
it was based on a hypothesis which you
observed that
we have high levels of ac2 so an entry
receptor for the virus in human
anthracites
and when he and others exposed
intestinal organs to the virus it was
not only infecting the androcytes but
also large numbers of progenitor cells
showing that it's really
affecting a variety of cells in the
intestine
using transmission em we could also show
that viral particles are indeed being
formed by these cells and finally using
bulk rna sequencing
we could characterize the inflammatory
response initiated
by epithelium affected with the virus
which has also been done by now in a lot
of different lung organoid lines
really trying to get a better
understanding of the immediate response
to this virus
once it infects a cell and all of this
was happening really within a couple of
months
uh showing that in vitro models which
have a proper self representation can be
really useful
uh to rapidly gain an understanding of
the new pathogen
now the last project i want to briefly
talk about a human entree endocrine cell
atlas which we built together with
again new burma and also julia baso
martinez martinez delgado
it was published in cell last june and
here we derived organized from many
different regions of the gut
to study a rare hormone producing cell
types a so-called enteroendocrine cell
labeling these enteroendocrine cells
with genetic
noggins for their hormones so to
be able to track the subpopulations
making different hormones in real time
again characterizing similar to the
snake project with a
deep single cell ionosequencing of a
number of cells
and also bulgarian sequencing and
secretomics so
characterizing the secreted products of
an organoid similar to what has been on
the snake project
but here in much greater detail to look
for new secreted products and
how hormones are being processed and
finally and this is the concept i want
to close with
uh organs are really versatile model to
do this discovery project which i've
been talking about a lot today
but also to do direct validation for
example for drug targets
for any patterns which we observe in our
singles of sequencing atlas
to do for example receptor knockouts on
these organelles to expose them
to compounds and to help be able to do
rapid comparisons between
human argonauts and mouse organoids to
pay particular attention to
interspecies differences
and as a last example here we identified
a receptor which is
expressed in a subpopulation of
enteroendocrine cells and with the
genetic calcium sensor
we can expose them to the known ligand
and track the response of human
enteroendocrine cells
in real time just serving as another
example of
the versatility of arguments to
characterize these kinds
of processes
with that i want to thank a couple of
people first of all
hans clavos who built a really large and
successful lab over the last decades
and keeps pushing out great organized
stories so really
having a great time working in this lab
and with everyone in there
making such a collaborative environment
to build these kind of projects
then as we meet us the biotech company
for building organ or
august on a chip enlightened in the
netherlands and especially the water
kubrick
i want to thank everyone involved in the
snake project again uh yuban zurich and
a large group of
collaborators mostly uh snake people
then um the e coli project team again a
large international consortium
and finally the entry endocrine cell
project team and yeah thank you to all
of you for
uh staying tuned for half an hour and uh
i hope we find some platform to discuss
for any of these projects if you're
interested get in touch and always happy
to have a chat